over kiru's new voice actor especially
his karaoke performance and this is like
a dragon um not infinite wealth but like
a dragon gayon the man who erased his
name shout out to Young yay we had him
on ILP before but um yeah it's a bit of
controversy While y yay himself posted a
clip of the English voice acting
performance alongside the original
Japanese version it was a karaoke clip
that really blew up in the Yakuza
Community many fans have shared their
less than enthusiastic response to the
performance While others have rushed to
defend Y and some have even called out
developer RI R rgg I'm just going to say
I always bu for not bringing in
professional singers so this has gone
extremely viral people are I'm not going
to read all the negative tweets it's a
lot but um basically I want to get y y
y's um response and he put out a series
of tweet and reference to this he said I
appreciate all those reaching out with
kind words on kiru always knew some
toxicity was coming or that no not
everyone would be on board but I'm glad
to see more people are warming up to my
version and I'm excited to for people to
see kiru's full Journey wish I could
show more he goes on I get the
apprehension you've been listening to an
iconic voice for almost 20 years and
have a very clear idea of how he should
sound my voice is not 100% match and
it's not supposed to be similarly to how
say English and Japanese versions of
snakes sound vocally distinct but
hopefully kiru's Aura and Vibe for the
English version will come across as you
hang out and become more familiar with
him I hope you warm up to him warm up to
it like I did there's a lot that hasn't
been shown and I'd show more if it
wasn't for me he said there's obviously
the option for you to pick your
preferred language um he goes on cuz
he's a long um he talks about you know
the new particular one and then I
believe someone cuz the toxic portion of
his message some people had an issue in
and someone said to him not all
criticism is toxic you need to learn how
to take your little chin and move on so
Yang yay responds he says I agree never
said that all criticism is toxic but
there's a line between being critical
and being a straight up a-hole and the
last thing I do want to add to this
discussion is some fans are pointing out
his critique of Chris P Pratt Mario's
voice and he has some comments in
reference to that and he said it wasn't
a good fit and you know people are kind
of trying to bring that up to to use
against them and say hey this is kind of
what we're saying I thought Chris Pratt
knocked it out the park I thought you
did a good job too fair enough so look
this is the big one this addict topic I
know you're passionate about it bro
let's get to it so
I played like an hour of the game and I
had to drop it just that that kind of
gamepl is just not for me yeah you know
I either want like realistic type of
stuff like that or completely off the
ball stuff and and I'm sitting there get
like some magical rope rapping around
people and I'm just like yeah I'm good
oh so you implying that the ichy bong
games are better right that's what you
saying like you likez atast ich they
acknowledge that ich agenda I know
I'm going push byend I'm going push like
at least at least with the the ich bomb
one they stay with all of it
like you cook it I'm trying but you keep
making ke I'm sorry I'm
sorry at least with the the Ichibon ones
like they just State we're full of it
like like everything is over the top you
know Ichibon is literally essentially
having a mental breakdown in his head
and everything else around him is normal
uh so you know but I
acknowledge they they they found a very
good middle ground to this is real this
is not real I feel like I feel like the
main characters in The yaka a regular
franchise they're anime characters in
the real world like it's like I played
that and when they were explaining the
how to play the game like he's sitting
there rapping with like like magical
rope and throwing them everywhere I'm
just like what are we doing I thought I
thought this was the realistic typ of
game the franchise used to be the
franchise used to be just beat them up
boom boom that's what it was and I'm
with I was was like all right you know
what I'm saying but but what about the
character him and then obviously the
voice acting which is the controversy
right
now all right so ironically the dove
version isn't out so I can't really
speak on the entire which is interesting
that it's not out because I would feel
like it would probably be out at the
same time I'm very curious you know
people in the chat did Sega ever come
out openly and and like explain why the
dubb was delayed cuz I haven't heard it
yeah I gotta ask something y hardcore
has this ever happened where the um the
dub is not out on release the English
dub at the same time I I don't know I
don't follow the Yakuza from from the
beginning yeah as far as like you know
Yang's I did see the stuff going around
on Twitter and it has been deemed that
that is from the game is dubbed I'm
pretty sure that's the from the game
it's just not it
it isn't you know when I listen to it
like I'm like I guess I'm W I'm W I'm
playing this game in sub like it's just
what even me not knowing this character
I listen to this and it doesn't sound
like like the verbiage that this
character would have like the way he
moves
himself one one quick second Nintendo on
on top he on it he said there was no
dubs at all until like a dragon he says
interesting interesting okay
so it's just like to me you know when it
comes down to this whole scenario it's
just like maybe because I I've been told
that some of
other y's is is drastically better this
maybe this just wasn't his role you know
because because it's like it it to me I
feel like I'm watching a Yang video like
it sounds like when he's talking to it
doesn't like like I felt like when he
was on our show and he was pitching his
voice up and down that sounded more like
voice acting than I heard seen on this
particular thing and and it's just like
it's sad because I I know this is so
important from Yong but at the same time
like blocking people that like I
understand that people generally being
an [__] towards you those people
deserve to be blocked but it's like
blocking people that are just saying yo
I didn't like this performance like
that's not a good look it's just not
because it's just like I I get it's hard
for me it's easy for me to say that when
I'm not in the moment like he was and
the whole world H your T Line This is y
we're talking about he should be used to
that fair fair enough like he's
constantly getting criticized for
everything maybe it becomes a time when
you sick and tired of being constantly
criticized for doing your best I feel
but facts at the same time man it's just
like you
know I like J as a content creator but
the more more I see him as a voice actor
like yeah I just personally felt like
there's no way they couldn't find
someone that sound more genuine to the
actual person that used to do it okay
fair enough fair enough Lord s the
Raging controversy like a Dragon Gate
and our man's young yay and it's it's
really spicy in these Twitter streets
man it's really spicy where we
at where we at
um I don't play Yakuza like that oh oh s
real quick he he's G to be one of the
Social Links and Persona 3 Reloaded as
well so so going right I know yeah Cog
mentioned this yesterday and let he may
he upset the Yakuza fan base upset the
Persona fan base they're they're very
extra well this is the thing I don't
think so I think that Yakuza stuff
upsetting that fan base is a little bit
different who was the main protagonist
right and some they been around for for
years but let off we interrupt us off we
always off apologize we always do sorry
I mean I I don't play them so I don't
don't know I know that I would play them
dubbed if I did play them right um I
played some a little bit but nothing
crazy like that I think I've I got like
maybe 10 hours into yaku Z zero which
was again the the previous voice actor
right I'm thinking that's the previous
voice actor if they did do a dub for
that um what I have heard of what the
previous voice actor has done in
comparison to Yang's um uh performance
in uh in Guiden and and also whatever
the little Clips they have of him and
infinite wealth I do sort of feel I
think we discussed this yesterday Cog
where it's like the older voice feels
like an older like like an older sort of
uh kiru whereas in right if you're
thinking about this guy that's at kind
of at reached the end of his journey
kind of or he's an older protagonist
yong's voice doesn't match that y's
voice sounds like a a younger version
that's fair whereas that the older voice
actor has more s of deep gravitas in his
voice that sort of fits an older version
of that that's all I would say about
that
um I just think for me what bothered me
about this whole
situation is
that you have to you have to stop and
think for a moment when you call out a
person for saying oh you you don't have
a thick skin you say these things but
then you can't take your medicine back
in return and you have to imagine what
that is like in real time like the
Internet isn't the same thing as real
life imagine millions of people coming
at you in real life we walk into a room
and there's a million people in there
yelling at you about how much you
suck it's hard it you know I don't care
what you said in the past I don't know
care what you said online or whatever
that's a difficult thing to to process
when it feels like the entire narrative
is that your version of this is no good
that's that's a hard thing to have to
deal with and I I agree to the point is
like well you know what you well you
know what you signed up for right to a
certain extent at the same time it
bothers me that so many people online
people that I consider to be cool and
good use that as a whataboutism is like
well well you know hey you know you did
sign up for this you are making millions
of dollars you know being a content
creator whatever you should be you
should know this is coming and that be
okay to have for them to have to deal
with and the fact of the matter no it's
not okay it's not okay how would get
always put yourself in somebody else's
shoes and say hey how would you feel if
somebody you you walked into a room
people just started yelling at you and
not yelling to good things basically
most of the narrative was this is not
good this is not and it's Bas again it's
based off of a small sample size fair
fair I I just the only push back which
we kind of discussed yesterday off the
Record is the where fans are saying okay
what you're saying is fair but fans are
like yo in the same token you went at
Chris Pratt for not being an exact match
for how Mario's voice should sound and
thus with that those receipts that
they're putting up like one thing one
thing I will say real quick is a big
content creator like Yang y going after
Chris Pratt probably resulted in a lot
of people going after Chris
Bratt I think yeah I mean would I say
that people online sort of created The
Narrative around Chris Pratt not being a
a good fit for Mario because I I know
the Casual didn't do the C the Casual
person who the who was probably the
majority of people who went to see this
movie right did not care that Chris
Pratt was Mario in fact was probably
excited that Chris Pratt was Mario right
yep and us the ones that are kind of in
the know that were around that
conversation a lot of us went to see the
movie and was like he was fine he was
really good because at the end of the
day Mario has to talk and in a way that
he's never spoken in any other product
right check the chat when you get a
chance I just send something keep
talking a part our personal chat or yeah
our our chat chat chat right now he had
to speak in a way that he's never spoken
in any product apart from maybe the
Super Mario Brothers Super Show right or
the the original Super Mario Brothers
movie with John leamo and uh and whatam
call it
um Bob Hoskins so to me it's like my my
thing is this yes should Yang probably
looking back on it was like Hey man me
being tough on these other voice actors
and not liking this although I'm
expressing my opinion came back to bite
me here because they were receipts that
says hey you're being a hypocrite you're
being a hypocrite um and he's going to
have to deal with that as as it is my
thing is think about for a moment before
you start ripping on one person how that
whole thing plays out and just just be
more thoughtful like when I look at I
looked at some of these chats and it's
like oh I threw up on my troller uh you
know stupid things you're the worst you
should die like what the hell that's
left that's left yeah that's left this
is where this is where to me and the
problem is that if you have actually
have something to say it gets lost in
all that dribble true true true and and
and and so when I can see somebody
looking at that and be like I don't want
to listen to any of it because all of it
feels like it's just negative even the
stuff that feels constructive or even
the stuff that isn't mean-spirited you
it it's still something you got to deal
with so again for me
at the end of the day there's choice and
from what I've heard most people just
play this with the Japanese voices and
and the subtitles anyway so if if it's
not for you hey I will say this though
he has he he has gotten other jobs Sega
obviously feels he's the man for and if
they feel after after this and infinite
wealth that he's not they'll change him
right do you think there's any truth to
the suspicions of delaying the English
dub based on any type of reaction that
they that they're getting right now or
you think that's be coincidental well I
mean that was again the the the delay of
the English dub I I heard about that a
while back that it wasn't ready right so
okay I don't know what the specific
circumstances behind that was but it
could be I mean now could be after this
reaction right because after this
reaction may maybe there's something
that says hey I don't know what we can
do clean this up a little bit or
whatever um to a specific point about
the about the
karaoke
again that goes back to Sega and
rgg
point like you you picked him you picked
him right so if you needed somebody that
sang better then that would that's on
you you picked him like you g to tell me
you didn't remember that you GNA have
these karaoke moments in the game and
then and then and to be fair technically
karaoke you're supposed to suck at
karaoke it's not like like that's
supposed to be the the
hottest carry up so it's like I don't
know man I think where I'm different
from you in this is I don't I don't
coign people dog piling people attacking
him on personal levels correct but at
the same time I'm all for the
constructive criticism as long as you're
respectful because this is also a
content creator individual that has
built his whole Roots off constructive
criticism on everyone else fair fair
yeah it's fair it's fair and I I just
think I think when he takes a moment to
think about it he's going to realize
that he was he's emotional in the moment
every feels like everybody's coming at
him and he probably made a few bad
decisions in in in in who he blocked and
because of what was said right and we're
human we that happens um at the end of
the day though at the end of the day
though like at the end this is my thing
at the end of the day maybe he doesn't
feel that way that's one and two
they hired him and he is the voice he is
the English dub voice for krier moving
forward until Sega says otherwise um you
don't like it don't listen to it um
people saying they're not going to play
the game as a result of it I don't I I
get it I maybe if you've always listened
if you've always if you came on board to
this series when dubs were a thing and
now you're not getting a dub that you
like I see you not you I I can see that
not you know wanting to continue but
beyond that like you have a choice to to
play it a different way play it a
different way and again if the if the
blowback is that heavy my I imagine that
Sega will do something about it um but
the man has also done other Voice work
that I don't see anybody bu sort of
egregiously sort of calling out and
saying is the
worst so to addict's point maybe it's a
it's a tough cell for people coming off
of this kind of iconic voice yeah that
that feels like it fits the character
perfect to a voice that feels younger I
remember and this isn't exactly a one
toone situation but we talked about this
last night as well you know splin Cell
Blacklist comes out there's no Michael
irons side is a younger and obviously
it's a younger version of Sam fer but at
the same time it just did not feel like
Sam Fisher at all because that voice was
so iconic right um we talked about metal
gear solid five and then you know Kima
decided okay David hay or whatever we
need keeper southernland to come in here
that was a big one and read what was
mostly a non-existent script for snake
in in that game so it's again it's a
preference thing just don't attack
people like that like be better about
that be better about that that is not
what the internet is for it's not no
it's not what the Internet it's not what
it is it's about that smoke son oh my
God if you for the smoke it's about that
smoke you can't be out here giving out
smoke and when smoke come your way you
like oh I don't like the smoke and smoke
one thing I will say is but smoke is
come his way but you got to think about
if if somebody come in here n no don't
worry I got it but if somebody come at
you no I know but again if somebody
start attacking you personally and
saying out of pocket things like out of
pocket then I shouldn't be I shouldn't I
should not be in a public space then
that's yeah I should not be in a public
space because let me tell you something
there's a reason why I put a camera on I
I put the camera on because I hope you
keep the same energy and put your camera
on too cuz when I see I'm smack you and
that's the thing I think people have
gotten comfortable with on law day
because you know what it is I come with
peace right so so if if if you got it
you got it but he I can't wait till you
finish I yeah but I will say this uh
it's it kind of feels like the level of
right there's no anonymity we know who
he is right but there is still that
barrier that buffer where it's like you
don't see these people and people are
still very willing to say all kinds of
wild stuff to you on the internet um
fact see
like yeah how you doing like yeah I I
catch you in that bathroom star like I
ran up on Mob deep and say yo speak to
my cousin
nowo to my cousin now that a he's
standing at the urinal like I'm like why
is Havoc from Mob deep on the phone with
me I'm like what is going on FaceTime my
czo
now thank you fun King for your Sunday
contributions let me run down on you I
catch
stop stop it it's the Lord's Day
continue the biggest thing I would just
say is you know take the criticism man
you know take the ones that you feel is
valid and improve your next performance
as them because you know I personally
didn't like it uh but you know I didn't
really I and this is coming from someone
that almost watches everything dubbed
right I'm used to bad dubbed but it did
didn't it just didn't feel like it just
felt like he was talking like it felt
like yeah that's the criticism right
that it was him being him it was him
being him and not acting um I mean we
we've seen that we've seen that a lot of
cir this scene I want you to be a
cowboy and it's like he goes I reckon yo
yall messy y messy yeah so again I will
say this if it's constructive criticism
also you know you have to also look in
the mirror like hey where can I improve
right where can I improve instead of
taking the other route and being like
super defensive about it and staying
that way that's not a positive thing
either the moment the moment he started
blocking people consistently and he
would like apparently Alex said he did
the research he was he was searching his
name on Twitter Alex thinks and just
proactively blocking people that were
negatively speaking it's just like the
moment you do stuff like that you got a
pre-
Block No but if he was he went on a
blocking spree if he was truly doing
that he used
AI if he was truly doing that all he did
was make it worse cuz now you're going
to get also people criticizing you
you're also going to now get people
criticizing you for blocking people
without even really having interaction
with them you're going to get the people
that are like yo why are you being like
this considering you do nothing your
entire
time you've been on YouTube criticizing
people so I feel like he opened like he
only had one door hitting him and then
when he started blocking people
proactively like that he opened up like
another four or five doors hitting it
yeah I would say it's not a good thing
if you start seeking out the negative
content about you use the AI algorithm
said listen anybody brought up my name I
want you to block him said
I you just see you just say you see kid
smoo blocking theme song in the
background the whole time he's doing
blocking blocking block so my my let's
let's all be better let's be better
let's attempt to be
better K I assume you have something
different to say so we GNA bring it to
you uh I saw the video I listened to it
I don't play the games I haven't played
the games I'm a fraud so like like when
it came in Game Pass I was capping for
it like d why
game a't ain't play none of
[Laughter]
them they he they just dropped another
one right now
[Applause]
play but I heard it and I was just like
oh sound like y so what um obviously
Sega wanted
Yang are y'all upset cuz they wanted
Yang are y'all upset cuz he dis Chris
Pratt like hey somebody you was talking
bad about Chris Pratt like mean this is
a beloved character snitching bro stop
snitching bro this a beloved character
that guy needed to get blocked but let
me let me I'm give a word of advice word
advice let's go let's go let's go
when you mute them they can't see
it I mute I will mute effective
m m is effective because he was on the
show yes I see mute as like a giant mute
in real life like I mute them they're
scaming on Twitter and I can't I can't
hear them I I'm telling you uh he was on
the show he super super proud of what
he's super proud right that's why I hate
this happen the most this is the I don't
care what happens to anybody
um I'm I'm you got to get what you going
to get whatever lesson you need to learn
you got to learn it so this is a learn
Learning lesson from him he didn't he
didn't lose he just heard a fan-based
criticism of how they felt about a
character that he portrayed now this
what happens when you dance to your own
music you come outside and you take your
dance moves to the club you thought you
killing it and you thought everybody
cheering you on but they was laughing at
you now now that this happened how do
you recover from this do you take this
and you work on your craft better so
that the next time you do this character
it actually hits where they want to feel
it um or do you curl up in your shell
start blocking people and point you're
the problem I'm not the problem you can
do it either
way I'mma tell you mute people so it
doesn't crash in all you all at once or
just go off Twitter for a few weeks like
some people some people can't this
addiction to this stupid little thing is
crazy um it's a it's a terrible
addiction but the problem is seeking
validation from
others will lead you to the road of Ruin
faster than anything else and what you
have to do is find that validation
within yourself now if you did your best
then that shouldn't bother you right but
if you felt that you left something on
the table I can see where the criticism
can start to affect you because you
didn't feel like you did your best but
if you did your best and that's all that
you can ever do in this world is do your
best and you came up short then so what
but you tried and you did you did what
the
99% aren't doing they're not trying
they're criticizing you for trying and I
want to hear their voice in a video game
I feel that I'll jump in look disclosure
Lord Cognito is
biased Lord Cognito is biased here um I
met young yay in person you know shook
his hand looked that man in his eye had
chopped it up great conversations and to
me he a real one when based on the vibe
and the energy that was presented I
spoke to a lot of people and I move
around in these Shin digs and stuff like
that and not everybody as is as they see
you know what I'm saying and I will say
my interaction was positive when he was
a man of his world he pulled up like he
pulled up a lot of people you know oh
I'll do it I'll do your show whatever
whatever he pulled up so look at the end
of the day does that mean he's absolved
from criticism no of course not you know
what I'm saying I listened to the the
performance I have to admit it sounded
more like young yay on a video young yay
as opposed to KIRO now mind you I am new
to the series I have not been with this
character from the beginning so everyone
knows what the inflection is and how
it's supposed to sound so to speak but I
will say this one like King said
Sega picked him rgg picked him so if you
have an issue with the performance they
coign this performance right so that's
you expect young yay not to take that
that's what I'm about to go and we got
to be a 100ed
y'all listen forget he's a fellow
content creator with me or whatever even
if he knew for a fact he could do that
the amount of exposure you would get
would be ridiculous your favorite
franchise pull up on you and say you
gonna be the voice of such and such and
we gonna give you a bet you gonna say no
s you're the you're the protagonist of
Red Dead 3 yeah you g to say no nah son
I don't need you going to try your best
or whatever whatever I'm not trying to
be disrespectful Sega allowed this they
all the ones that co-sign and said yes
now I have no reason I am not a voice
actor but if the man gave his best and
they say yep that's it is he supposed to
say nah son I don't you know I ain't
ain't really worthy of this just yet y
I'm here's we got be 100% And I had this
yesterday which
is there are certain roles think of this
King like Optimus
Prime right if God forbid it's iconic
well God forbid well they have killed
otimus shut
up about that Peter shut up what's it
look like shut up I hate you right now
you should pull it up so we are not
pulling up time on y'all I my point but
here's my point these iconic roles God
forbid if I Peter cullin passes away
right there's a there's a replacement
roll up for the famous Optimus Prime and
some dude come out with Optimus Yes Yes
Y'all let's roll out y'all right y'all
going to throw tomatoes at the screen
they got they got red man is optim red
man is Optimus right so so if Red Man
come out Optimus he go he go Autobots to
the
streets right you going to be like yo
this is the wor
unless you copy
get work your magic Autobot do that
thing unless
you do the black
girl black
Autobot Jazz and Blaster the homies I
you say it now we got to go Auto bot the
5's on it so chill chilled oh you had it
Autobots one time
but yeah Autobots there's 12 on the
corner oh some people were asking about
my uh shirt it's a Jitsu kaisen shirt
dope so all I'm saying is the the person
is an the L unless they straight bite
the style of Peter Cullen right and you
imitate Peter color version that's the
only way you safe it's the same way with
someone particular starcream you know
starcream is Iconic with the Y Mega Mega
like if you don't do that you Y Mega my
D
what it ain't going to go so that's all
I'm saying we got to he was in the L
regardless if he did not try to attempt
to do the English DB version of kiru
regardless that's all I'm trying to say
but you know at the end of the day I do
understand you trying to say they set
him up listen they I you know who
somebody told me to shout to KATU we do
know as great as yaka is it is is not a
franchise that has sold well in the west
so to speak so again I'm not trying to
disrespect young the man's been doing
voiceovers and stuff prior to this and
all that but we have to admit that he
does have a fing but over 1 million subs
or whatever right this is a huge guy I'm
got curious he's got a huge following
did he make more than the average voice
actor would make for
this watching I a parcking watch it no
I'm not parcking watch what I'm
wondering a whole poet watch question
can you let me finish my
statement from someone that normally get
this because he does have that YouTube
following is he allowed to ask more I'm
kind of curious I'm like I don't know
how that goes I how to B all I'm trying
to say I can tell you how it goes how it
go I can tell I got a million
subscribers you try to give me the check
that the dude that got 10,000
subscribers got we ain't doing that bro
I got a million subscribers my people
don't like what you just said to me what
if they give you a million subscriber
bread you taking it yeah all right I'm
look at like they're stupid and all
right then so I ain't going to get mad
at my man for taking the bag and and
they said yes and guess what you get to
say King David is the voice
Mega the new voice of Mega if Phil hit
me up and 343 said we need you to be the
voice of um a master chief well you got
that
EX I I'm kind of curious how ke would
handle Master Chief's voice yeah same
way I can't handle all voices the same
Hold the
Line do a master Che
voice King no no no King we got to hear
Spartans out we got to hear that right
now now roll let's roll out
Spartans at the end of the day look I
get it if you don't like it bro just
switch to Joint switch to Joint put your
dub on and that's it but I understand
the criticism I understand it and
hopefully like I said it's a learning
experience from him with this whole
situation on how to handle but I do
understand the whole world coming at you
too it's kind of crazy it is what it is
W you know I have a very small following
I couldn't imagine what like to have
imagine
you and you got a million everybody's
bombing on you it's the human element
y'all the human and that's the people
imagine everybody people that follow you
that don't follow you cuz that's the
worst when people that you you that
follow your content that you think are
just positive on you in general just
ripping into you and then they had the
direct line to you as well you know fun
every every time someone speaks to like
negative about an opinion or something I
had on Twitter first thing I do is see
if you follow me on Twitter like I'm not
going to lie like I have a very